[Music] yes, what should I say now, dear colleagues, dear colleagues, ladies and gentlemen, and now the third one, I've been thinking, what do you say to the alu ihle, dear friends, I could sound wrong, or dear friends, that's neutral, we want you today
actually presenting a new book and my colleague professor for the struck and i we thought about showing him what labora depths and instrumental possibilities existed in the past and present here in the museum we still have enough time afterwards to discuss and ask questions
i also built up a bit of historical instruments and then we can use these devices to talk a little bit about their functionality so now i have to make sure that i am here too i would ask you not to cover the picture when you look at
the museum of natural history thinks or even visits it then one first thinks of s
auriers at exhibitions i also hope a little bit at the mineralogical exhibition but essentially at exhibition but the museum is more like I said we are more than just an exhibition you know this picture but the core and the working basis of everything we do what we do for
making exhibitions but also doing science are the more than 30 million objects from our natural history collections and our website says they are the core infrastructure of the museum, i.e. the basis for everything we do there have been a number of books about the museum recently published great
ordnung art 2010 deals with the history of the museum it's about how did the collection come about who worked here in which knowledge things from the ore were published in the second edition by römer verlag it's actually about which stories the museum objects tell us
or even the museum, what will we say, so to speak
what are you telling us that is very much in vogue at the moment is the discussion about the origin of objects and one of these books that deals with it is about the dinosaurs that were excavated in what is now tanzania at the beginning of our century and can be discussed using this example
how do you deal with such objects is that it makes a difference whether you excavate something that is not man-made or whether you destroy culture and i think these questions are discussed in many different ways in this book and ultimately we also have a question of origin
us 2009 10 times busy with what is actually so about the dear god himself so alexander von humboldt came to our museum so what things do we have to thank him for and 2009 10 was that humboldt was his 250th birthday and then we have business
but this is not just about historical things, you should also talk about very current things g
that's why i researched the number down there in 2009 10 that's at least 366 scientific covers that were created here in the house and very few were created well well only from the head let me say that there is in the band about
certain things are philosophized but that's not normal, they are the result of scientific investigations and most investigations need instruments and that's an aspect that has actually hardly played a role in considering the history of our house so far the results will always be the same
but rarely talks about how you came to these results and a first step that we have taken towards it i have been thinking about it for years supervisor actually or i actually also put them together out of sheer cost him and limit the collection of historical instruments i will only
20 years ago I still have a good 20 to say
years ago, mrs. hensen hansen helped the group and a book came out of it. i also wanted to tell you something and if you so because only about it will the uli struck talk about it afterwards it's about the path to computer tomography, so to speak to the very modern methods, yes
in the next few minutes or hours i would like to introduce you to some of the instruments that i think are particularly important and instruments that i know about, what happened to them, who used them and where they come from, i don't know about all of them
instruments but i know that quite well about some of them and i would like to introduce you to them a little bit the oldest instruments we have are older than the museum so the museum was established in 1810 they come from the society of motor researching friends and interestingly enough they didn’t serve the
scientific research but educational work if you will
en the museum’s second major concern is the educational work, so it lasts well over two years, yes, it is not an instrument, yes, yes, I want to, I don’t know if there is anyone else who doesn’t, yes, it’s about so-called solar microscopes, microscopes, if you will
are the forerunners of slide projectors slide projectors we need a very strong light source and the sun microscopes had the following principle you had made a board in the last hole instead of the window cut a hole in it screwed the microscope in front of it, so to speak, in front of this hole and behind it there is a
I also brought 1 mirror for you to look at later on there is a mirror that you can both tilt and rotate so that you can always see the sun 1 cent and then it is thrown onto the wall via a projection you can see that on the picture above and you have it
advertised one of the manufacturers has advertised that one could use such an instrument to fl
ow is the size of an elephant those things were very popular and very widespread our tribe as I said we have two pieces and come from the society nature researching der Freude zu berlin i think founded in 1773 in 1810 the university was founded and three museums were established with it
i would now like to deal very briefly with johann wilhelm illegal unfortunately i have so far and also in the museum we don't know what he looked like but probably like many others also the builder illegal and harry liga was before he headed the museum before the museum the zoological museum
he comes from biology and has dealt with the beetle of prussia and most of the beetles he described were less than two millimeters meant only half a millimeter in size he couldn’t have examined them without and an optical instrument that’s not possible we don’t know
water used i have only two choices out g
Looks like he could have used such a very nice so-called simple microscope up there, shown in 1762 a little before league worked and below a microscope that is the oldest mobile microscope that we have, the microscope from a so-called hof matches microscope 1780 i
I will say something more about this microscope in a moment because it is one of the instruments that we know quite a lot about, yes, it is different and you can see that such small drawings of beetles came out of it, I will also briefly say something about this later, yes, then again, gold, you know this famous one
painting the forum, by the way, humboldt didn't like at all because all of them are, so to speak, wrong instruments are shown in this picture who didn't have with him at all had completely different instruments with and also quite so it and there always discussed the role of sweets is more like an auxiliary fleet here
pushed like that, humboldt never saw it
because he saw him as an equal partner on his travels i have circled it the painter has shown there the painter eduard end has shown a microscope there on the table i have put it next to it in large size this is our example in sohland is nuremberg microscope the nurembergs
microscopes have been sold for almost 100 years and they got their name because they were sold via nuremberg so they come partly from southern germany and from different and but were all built similarly there are several types this is the most common type with this wooden box and the tube
in which the lenses are housed is made of cardboard and first of all this microscope is bad after not particularly good even in humboldt's time and secondly it would never have survived the tropics that would probably have gone moldy after a few days in the jungle or been eaten by insects or something similar it has the following
he has such an ebe
n already presented the hof matches microscope with unfortunately our hof matches microscope is not from humboldt it is not exactly known so if one is lent out for exhibitions that of the german museum will be lent out but also a copy but even there it is not clear whether that
really humboldts is microscopic ours has a very exact origin that comes from cheerfully expected from rock a german nobleman and education reformer in the rack with in brandenburg he was briefly squatter and has a school there for his subordinates i don't know if the peasants who were still serfs at that time
but in any case, the school and he unfortunately almost blinded himself with microscopy in the end went blind and so he could no longer use the microscope properly and warmly corresponding member of the society of friends of natural sciences and gave it to the society in 1805 by then that was actually it
a bit out of date
well he has the box but the then president of the society thanks him and promises to use it often as said friedrich eberhard von rochow the nineteenth century is the century of the turbulent development of microscopes until around 1870 microscopes were essentially made or good microscopes were based on experience
the microscope manufacturer, back then, you couldn’t calculate optics, you had the problem of optical errors under control to some extent, but by trying and the second big problem was, firstly, you couldn’t calculate it and secondly, you couldn’t produce glasses reproducibly, that was the glasses
it's not bad but different for spectators that means you couldn't define a lens manufacturer that wasn't possible you couldn't yet that carl zeiss noticed and tried to do the math himself that he didn't succeed he also writes himself that his mathematical skills weren't there
would not have been enough and he looked for the young physicist ernst but from thuringia who had just calculated the first microscopes, i.e. calculated the optics and he also noticed that the teachers are the be-all and end-all of this whole thing defined teachers with defined
physical properties and he looks for the young otto schott who originally comes from the rhineland and builds with him and the son of carl zeiss roderich zeiss he builds the schotten glass works that are in mainz today and i think in jena there is no longer the german glass mountain
on otto schott and comrades that's what they used to be called and comrades were serious abbe and roderich time and with these defined glasses that you could make the microscopes make a real evolutionary leap in quality but not only in quality but also in price these things are all at once
20 30 times as expensive as the microscopes used to be and people always say, well, a microscope like that
a normal employee at zeiss had to work for more than a year in order to be able to possibly buy such a microscope they were really expensive they are, so to speak, and since the seventies early 80s this time in the microscope as I said has been the standard at the time of the
quality of microscopes we own two from this relatively early production you see because the year 1888 and 1890 at zeitz works wonderfully you send an e-mail to the district archive and you get an answer and they tell you when the thing was made and when you
luck have also been delivered a little so zeiss is relatively good in this story i would now like to introduce you to a microscope that is so special that i have here i can't tell you who used it, just that it was used in the museum
but we do not know by whom here I present you a microscope that both today 10 mi
kroskop after hanson i also set that up there on the table, namely viktor hense professor of zoology in kiel at the university of kiel first dealt with examining fish easily and not only qualitatively but also quantitatively examining them and he has a microscope for that
invented or had built by the workshop zicker tim k, namely a microscope which is ultimately a large XY table a very large XY table with which you could put liquid preparations between the broken glass and so say something not only qualitatively but also quantitatively about the
composition of the fish viktor hense also coined a second term, namely the concept of planning which goes back to victor hensen previously it was called buoyancy that comes from johannes müller once our two pillar saints from the museum he has the money and hensel called it planning
and our microscope comes from karl abt ste
cut off in karl was a student of hensen and was primarily concerned with freshwater plant on and also became known as a participant in the is i was told the laser light would not work here yes what that is that is yes distance to the famous
berlin expedition of the first german deep-sea expedition that really contributed a lot to the exploration of the deep-sea regions and these are the results of the expedition such regulations that belong to the plankton he was he practically involved but not only that means the good microscopes built
many others have moved to famous companies are, for example, according to seibert winkel these are such famous companies and here again two microscopes of which i can say quite exactly who they are from you see there on the left side alfred keller alfred keller was a taxidermist here and
model maker and you can see him preparing one of his models
i will tell you in a moment what he has for this microscope what you see in the middle uses a saudi microscope and he has a microscope from wetzlar as a preparation microscope lends the other large company time so these are the two heavyweights he uses
or that have been used and you can see on the left picture the folders he offered the preparations are housed and here you can see they were made around 1920 and there you can also see the beauty of the details on this button they are the classified information are like that
pronounced as scallops that i think is a nice detail that even in such simple things you just develop a certain sense for beautiful things yes those are the things and have become known or what keller is investigating there that is known and that is the preparatory work for his
rainbow model this rain pro model was created in 1950 and if you want to see it in pots
dam go because the natural history museum there is on permanent loan, so to speak, and of course he has become known for his preparations from the sparkling wines, some of which are still here in the house, so above all the aviator is certainly one of his best-known preparations and the quality is still there
pretty unique that's how it looks today certainly no longer has the charm of the old devices this is a latvian polarization microscope here now so with what you do nowadays electronic camera all sorts of analysis devices on it that's how it looks today's workplaces and a lot has changed as a result
changed to that i will come shortly afterwards in the preparation of this book i have now looked through many rooms closets archives and when i saw it i just thought i didn't think it was anything special for him but i thought he has someone to the small
telescope has taken that somewhere a
n screwed and it looks a bit self-made and also but it was used 4 times until I then tried to get behind the history of this instrument and today I am very proud that we have this instrument at all there are probably too many of them for you
namely it is a so-called vestian magnifying glass the famous French instrument maker chevalier has one of these magnifying glasses parts on finds, so to speak, the power is about 10 times magnification works with a relatively large distance and is especially color corrected very well and the theology professor in
rostock franz schulze later a professor here in berlin thought we could combine two referred cavaliers minutes put them at a certain angle and then we would have actually done a great stereomicroscope said and you see that was at the psychological and physiological institute of the university of ros
tock instead unfortunately found no picture in love either he was mechanics and optics kiss was mr. westin put these two together, so to speak, and the vestian magnifying glass was created at the same time as schulze was a professor of theology in rostock a second man in rostock and wants a distorting one
once the famous ophthalmologists early ophthalmologists and he has the following i thought whether this magnifying glass was really great thought let's just turn it around 90 degrees so don't look down but look ahead and then you can see the child of a test person or examiner here
expose and then you can use it to examine the cornea, that means this Vestische loupe, which was originally a preparation for snooker, has become a corneal microscope, so to speak, or the so-called colonial loupe amber and westen at night and that’s how it went down in medical history, so we kind of have it
predecessor of these ten best super
So I find it very interesting how some devices or how you sometimes get behind the story devices yes this Belgian magnifying glass has a problem you cannot change the magnification at will and the following happens when you change the magnification the image is suddenly inverted and
is on the head the physicist who had already said the oven had to be able to solve it, namely through prisms wanted to develop a prism system went to the german empire to the german patent office and said we know this one i want
I had this double reversal system patented so both sides swapped and turned upside down and got the result that it's gentle that's been around for over 50 years and that an Italian named Pooch invented it and these are present
gone as so-called prisms and you realize that with telescopes imm
he then when, so to speak, the eyepiece and objective are not in a line but with such a normal woman makes room and bends our respect for glass and then there is a so-called porro prism in it and that is one here from Ernst Leitz in such preparation microscopes
the surgical microscope, so to speak, always that’s why these hand rests always mean that you can calmly work there, yes, then an american comes in front of him too, unfortunately, i couldn’t find a picture, only of his father, that was a very famous sculptor, we love, and that sabrina has
said let's arrange two of such microscopes at a certain angle then we actually have something like a stereomicroscope which entomologists in particular have been looking for for a very long time and he 1 1 but sent his suggestions from the staff of
abc then realized that and zeiss ended the e
first stereo microscope that meets today's demands, so to speak, brought onto the market the so-called stems from its terrible abbreviation stand it was called and that was, so to speak, and this type is still named after the green afp when it comes with two optics, each with a prism these microscopes the
stereomicroscope is both of the ruin on type that's also on the left side and in the middle of the so-called abitibi something else came up to reach places he used very large lenses and looked obliquely through both lenses and only those
edge areas used and could that has many advantages and here you can see two of our famous scientist, who is unfortunately no longer alive, is a scout gruner zoologist first director makes the walls of the house on the cuba expedition at the end of the 60s and one of the world-famous bug specialists woman exactly
scheiding on such microscopes, so to speak
they are by far the most common type of microscope in our house yes we'll switch subjects for a moment we'll go into mineralogy around the turn of the 18th and 19th centuries trying to figure out why crystals actually have such shapes make such relatively political shapes and
there were various theories about this but it was important and you start measuring the angles between the crystal surfaces because the goods are very important for understanding at the beginning you did that with so-called investors and then i also exhibited it here and then
later with optical consumptions there were different processes with such mirrors and with telescopes i know this here i can show you here you can always see mineralogy in the room i didn't want to open the showcase now there it is in a showcase that deals with maternal and rose
and with this account, mitzscherlich has a ga
nz made a major discovery and examined it shared so cold saves crystals and found that the crystal angle changes with temperature that these angles are, so to speak, temperature-dependent not great for this you needed very precise measurements, so in the minute range you had to measure the seconds range angles seconds range and
that was not compatible with any of the real classical theories today we know that you can only explain it with marketer theory there is no other way to explain this effect so there were theories that said forces of attraction and repulsion were in balance or there was no such theory
judges in the circus ring modular theory where you put such small stones on top of each other also that it cannot be explained with these things so to speak with this angle measurements through rosa and mitscherlich rose was yes here professor head of mineralogy no me here in the main building they have that
so to speak
this theory overturned these bonus meters are further developed there comes one rotates the circle opposite the previous instrument in the horizontal introduces an observation telescope 1 and 1 illumination apparatus a curator introduces one and one of the once the first usable instruments was me from grot
later head of munich famous mineralogist but he was a student of rosa and he partially came up with these things when he was here in berlin rose's successor as head of this institute bar martin debski and martin web ski invented the so-called web ski spalt that
means that a special lighting device for new meters and with this modern, very precise work of meters, mineralogy and crystallography are revolutionized and the highlight of these things are the so-called atlas of the crystal form of victor goldschmidt must always be careful there are two victor goldschmidt geochemists
and
but as I said, cristallo count and he put together a table over the course of many years you have to imagine that he collected all the crystal drawings known up to that point these are at least I skipped that I didn't count it I have about five tables and then I have
i took the board it's easier and i came up with about 25,000 crystal drawings on 100 1506 in new volumes and that was actually the cristallo graphic knowledge of the time and it wasn't just fun old puberty he had enough money and has
also rich married he could afford it and then that was practically the basis of the crystal determination or mineral determination you could determine the mineral is very well based on the angle and this method was actually practiced for years before it was replaced by insight graphic methods
has been yes kay meters are geba until the 80s
ut that was once out of the house no longer the right to do that i managed to do that and i have never worked metrically that what you see there are very funny crystals from rüdersdorf that we measured once today it doesn't matter anymore
that conti migrate these gledson kilometers are no longer created for the determination of or for the basis of crystal drawings but one has built up with this course meters crystals oriented on geometer heads to examine zero graphically that was in the end the main thing or use the skin
of such kilometers for really cristallo graphic angle determinations, they have practically no longer been used yes we make a leap make a leap into the year 1829 and 4500 kilometers to the east the latitude the geographic latitude is pretty much the same drivers of the age at the altar with us today must
they say there are 250 kilometers near ancient russia
nothing at all before the real mountains start it's about 250 kilometers and it was one of the most famous smelting works the age the museum in the former laboratory building that also existed in 1829 this museum and that's the entry of humboldt depending on which calendar you use end
july or beginning of august you have the russian or he has been there and thanks for the miracle tree visit and you put a piece of ore in front of him or his companion gustav big the new one had taken with you that you couldn't do anything with big makes the following pants grab his sample
cutlery off that means it's a pyrotechnic investigation method to determine the feminism of things if you even if you still have gas at home many don't have it anymore and you blow a bit of soap powder in it the flame becomes all yellow and just like that
what does it do? the sodium turns the flag yellow and you end up doing exactly the same thing
s with one needs and he finds it is a heart with tellurium so what is rather unusual big pieces yes further the expansion does not find there is the trend takes the piece home and describes two minerals from this doctor chunks the
so-called it also has a silver telluride and the altar is a wide telluride the two, so to speak, based on this type of sample that saw in bar and found that taylor is in it 1889 we move into this house and we are now dealing with the mineralogist with comments
do as you can see and you will see it in the next picture as well wearing beautiful gardens has a long tradition in this museum you just have to look at our direct he has a wonderful and you can see that is not primarily a hair dress
that we are dealing with you see he has achieved a bit it's built like that but the others were too
from small the crystal physicist rated very nicely and he was very concerned with the optical properties of crystals, so what are the optical properties and crystal shape and how are they related because the optical properties in crystals are not all the same but are direction-dependent and that is
an instrument for which i found a sign that it came from a young age, so to speak, from him and he had some of these instruments directly in steglitz berlin steglitz at the famous company brother foot was pronounced he comes from westphalia and since i let myself be taught his name is again
foot but rather but that's a long one and the double it's actually long there are also places in soest for example it doesn't mean sweet but that's the way it is and it's the same yes he's a foot or foot a gifted mechanic who's very
has many very famous mineralogical instrumentations and this is an ins
trument where you can, so to speak, turn a crystal in a liquid and then examine it under the microscope yes yes this this knowledge about the properties of optical properties ground plan parts it is then applied in mineralogy and leads to this determination of such from these or to the use
instruments have been found of these properties for determining crystals and the highlight of this method is certainly that the solid microscope after brandao kleist brandao was a portuguese mineralogist and this is probably one of the most valuable instruments we own so don't ask there you get a mid-range car for leads
the instrument yes so the chief mechanic had to work for several years to be able to afford such an instrument what was it used for it was used for the so-called rock gap determination so falls later are made up of three components generals most commonly wed
neral of the earth's crust are made up of three components from the car claus albert and on the moped and the determination of the chemical composition of these later says a lot about the genesis of the rocks and with the help of these optical properties that was the only method where you could look at such
small crystals could ultimately determine how they must be put together here and then be able to draw conclusions about the genesis of the rocks that here the material is finished there is clearly the large crystal on the left and the gray crystals on the right are the feldspar crystals you do it very differently today
method has been lost today you do something like that with a micro but you can chemically analyze series of relatively small objects yes again briefly I'll write microscopes on the move in the past, at least from a certain position that you had in science, the microscopes were something like personal tools like
i
n fountain pen or wind writing and
the microscopes were also taken from
work to work
with two of them that is
exactly my recently deceased after
doctor father that is not a spelling mistake
he really turned 102
professor hoppe had this microscope in
1954 in jena in halle where he was first
bought it so took it to
greifswald and took it to
berlin so that is and also the
second microscope professor we
studied with or i
studied briefly if they immediately from building the wall
or a year from building the wall he
still made it, so to speak, as
microscope so from wetzlar and west
microscope one took this
microscope with him to greifswald
he became the successor of hopp
in greifswald and then came back
here to berlin and
this microscope also went on a journey, so to speak
, that is practically
no longer the case  so today the
mik  roscopes so close to the limits of
large devices, you have to say that
they have so much electronics and so much
technology behind them that here is a look
at the mineralogical microscopy laboratory
in the museum, that’s how it looks today,
so a lot of very
different microscopes understand it, but the last ones
in the end they are no longer on the
researcher's desk,
but we use the microscopes
not only for scientific work, so to speak,
but also
in educational work. we have
been running a microscopy center for many, many years,
where you can ultimately
bring children, young people, but also adults
into the world  the small of the small
can introduce, so to speak, come on
, I would have promised you that
illegally back to this drawing
later this drawing you can see
they are relatively imprecise and then for
scientific purposes you have one,
so to speak, and show with this
drawing from the  year
2013 is about a beetle  rt that was
described by illegal 1800
you can imagine that the army requires a high level of graphic ability
instead of such a drawing
and is certainly not suitable for entire
collections and
therefore reproduces very precisely what
you actually see on the beetle and
since then  i think it was
opened last week so in individual cases
we've been doing it a bit longer
today, so to speak, the modern
collection exclusion through mass
digitization, ie
the beetles are photographed with a very conspicuous photographic process that in front of
a 90 percent neutral gray that
the colors  still correct and you can
see how amazingly
detailed these photographs are
so don't do it with your cell phone
camera, it's a very
complex photographic
process and there's an idea that
by 2030 you want to create all 15
million objects insects  so on this
a  the way to take
pictures uli will say something about that
right away the big wish is still
to look inside non-destructively we
can do that structurally with
minerals but with fossils you
have to prepare them very conspicuously in
order to see what is inside  is
today we can do that perfectly but we will
say something about it right away yes
and i wrote a book with the photographer war götz
the teachers today can not
health is not quite on the
post and that is
the reason for presenting this here
today that  lives above
all from the photographs was in
the jazz series and a total of
68 instruments from the
museum are presented in this book i have only
shown a few here with their stories and
you see the manual microscope what
you see there is the title
devices yes I'll finish the text
and there you will of course always
find what you don't know yet
i wrote here on the right side a
rare polarization microscope from the
company seibert mostly stefan
leiting also by foot but they
are relatively rare but
unfortunately i only discovered that when we
had already finished the text and will have to
change everything second edition  does it come
with tires and i have found other
such rotary machines or
such
and i might write before 18
how do i get that someone used
a piece of this purple velvet dont
ask me with
this song like velvet the typical
foot why that
I don't know what is cut from it and you can see
the manufacturer has immortalized himself there
and I looked in the business books
from the 1990s
and it
says haiti and federal south
Berlin so Berlin is steep schreiberstrasse that's the
way it is  old jakobstraße there in the area
so not so much
there that in the area and you s
below is, so to speak, i found that in the
address book from 1895 habermann stahl schreiberstraße 37 then
comes 96 it shows up again
as habermann and sons and then it’s
gone then the company must have gone
under or moved somewhere else but in
berlin  address book you can't find them
anymore and that's why it's different the
instrument was built before 18
195 because in stock there
are those that aren't these devices
you have to say in the case of individual production
they weren't series devices yes yes I have
to steam I have to thank of course
our  direct general director am
vogel and mr. junker, our head of
administration, who kind of inspired me to write this book
and who
ultimately financed it generously
, i have to
say that, of course, i feel bad for the photographers,
that they don't have the project today,
then mr. ulrich moritz  in a tried and
tested way that I didn't look too much at
our scribe and the ge  stalter and
very important and i have to say it
was a great cooperation it shows
like
thomas thomas schmid answer that is the whole
coordination with the administration
or since i am no
longer an employee of the museum i am not allowed to
manage any money i have to
look for someone who  the money was managed
and in this case it was ms
hermannstädter who did it in the tried and tested
way and then of course i have
julia to thank julian
nee writes i
don't do it but here i do it
because she is known by that name in the house
A good 20 years
ago, we noticed that
Julia did a degree in museum customers at what was then the
University of Applied Sciences for Technology
and Economics
the instruments we still
use today that is ultimately fra  u
otherwise i probably would have had to put a
lot more work into it many
thanks na and the publishing house
i have to
try dancing prognosis at the bauer von
reimer publishing house i have to say i
felt very well looked after at all times and also in
good hands  with our book and i
hope that we can continue working together
yes i have
to vape thank you very much for
your attention for your attention
yes then i can only tell you
the book can be bought in the shop it can be
purchased 29 euros 90  I
think such a nice book is a cheap
thing to advertise a bit
yes good ok that's it actually
thank you very much and now you're
not that long
[applause]
it's now to jan o
deserve thank
you very much that's really impressive very impressive that you
because you took the trouble
to research all this and the colleagues who
helped
independently, of course, of course,
i would also like to introduce myself briefly before my name
is an expression i am the head of the museum
for natural history of the isotope laboratory, so
in the middle i have
to do the analysis of materials that accumulate here in the museum, but
also with international national
cooperation partners,
albeit a little at the same time
involved in teaching at the free
university
i'm a micro paleontologist by training that means
i grew up with the microscopes
i.e. collages and then in
the 90s I reached the limits of
the desktop marx for mineral oil micro
paleontologists what i actually quite
I found it a shame because my know-how, so to
speak,
didn't do me any good, but I
quickly got into this analytical
track because it's getting more and more involved in
natural history research and
thus
also expanding the level of knowledge,
in particular optical processes do
n't destroy the optical author  ears
are commonplace today but they
are not that old so we
started
with the
scanning electron microscope in can
you all still remember it was around
the 70s that you had so-called
images that made this three-dimensional
impression of objects such as
small animals,
insects and  what they said created a
nice picture that previously
the colleagues had to draw by hand with the microscopes
that was of
course a quantum leap
for research now you could observe things in the
micrometer range that
you otherwise had to somehow reproduce yourself via the picture
using
drawings  and i can now
make a very brief run through the laboratories of the museum
for natural history,
which
developed as a result in the 80s 90s and the
fracture mitri for mineral determination
but then also level material analysis
could analysis but we
have at the earliest  now also one  bio-
acoustic laboratory 3d laboratory I have
a small example of this geochemical
laboratory wing there it is the micro
probe there
elemental analyzes are carried out in nanometer-sized objects that
means we have the possibility of
finding extremely small particles or
minerals in rock that are
in  in the case of intact
meteorite impacts that was
possible before
and then there is a zoological
research laboratory isotope laboratory this is
my small example
molecular genetic laboratory
dna analyzes are carried out
paleontological preparation laboratories they
have probably existed for the last
hundreds of years, i.e. since the
museum  exist as fossils before
they have to be prepared so that they
can be characterized optically at all
and then this collection is maintained by laboratories
that then fix the objects that come into the collection
so that they don't expire that
's a very big problem in the
collections that the materi  aliens that were
used 200 years ago had to be poisoned, for
example, so that they would not
be eaten again by other organisms
, which of course means
that long-term
contamination prevails here and these are things that are
examined in these collection care
laboratories
but also processed at the same time  will that
means be restored and on
the next page you can see
that 3d lab
so now these are the two examples
was has already mentioned the
3d lab isotope couple of pictures
mixed in of typical objects from
the collections as they are there today
represent and that 3d laboratory that
basically gives us non-destructive images of the
inside here a
technique is used where an x-ray through x-
rays in a
revolving table
the different layers in an
organism or an object are
recorded and you can then later
digitally with  computer technology
reconstruct and so you can,
so to speak, remove everything layer by layer,
from the skin to the
body's internal organs to the substance of the bones,
which you can
already see quite well here on the skull, the devices
that we have here in the museum, they are
different in size than they are  being able to
see the big one that's for big organ
that has an eerie energy from being
shot x-ray energy so
you can penetrate larger
objects and that small one on the bottom right of
the picture that's the micro ct that was
first bought in 2010 and that's
his job  dissolving smaller organisms in the
micro range and these the
methods made further
ensure that we can also immediately examine the in the
organisms, for example revolutionary
trends i'll show you the next picture
that you couldn't
see before because you basically the the
freely  had to prepare and so you can
reconstruct on the spot where
certain components d  bodies have
settled and according to the
amount of objects that we
have, of course, an incredible
potential for new
results that could come out and
that is basically what I have
already said, the task for the
next ten years at least
probably more like 100 years the
objects  we first have to scan
the digital
hearts and then make them available to the public
a big
challenge but also an important
task but we as a museum
are sitting on our treasures and cannot let everyone in here
and so it will
probably be in  Shortly or with time it will be
possible to make many of the objects available to the
population, i.e. to ourselves, to
society and also to
interested scientists
, as a
three-dimensional object,
digital object that you can print
out for teaching, for example, or
then look at for scientific investigation  n without
having to come here in person
and accordingly perhaps these
objects adorn or dismantle them and
so they are non-destructively reserved for us in the
long term that means we
have the digital database of
as many objects as possible that we have here in the
museum and you can see them down there  the
whole
class the objects put in a glass
that are now stored here in the night collection it
is also an
effort to make them available to the guest or the board
so this
digitization is an important
goal for us in the next few years and my
own area of work that  is the
isotope laboratory in the isotope laboratory
you do mass spectrometry and we come
back to optics here gases
are also examined and the
isotope ratios in the gases and
these gases are just not
optically visible in any way it is
co2 or nitrogen dioxide
so it increased in
20 years  nitrogen but we can
through a through the ionization u  nd
by focusing with a young
optics here an electric
optics is used to determine the isotope ratios
in these materials and
with that we can reconstruct living conditions and the corresponding climatic conditions in the history of the earth
but also today
and that is also
a certain quantum leap because
now you not only  can study the objects themselves
, but can also examine their way of
life in the history of the earth in the
past and i now
have a very interesting
example like you all, which is really
quite close to us because it is just a
few patient meters away, namely
the brachiosaurus and  never has she here
is like that said the old question on
finally keys were also made with
isotope technology whether they were blossoms were
or not there has been a clear statement since the
jura stick park film
that probably was bloody they
were moving fast they  run in
stove  en they attack each
other and are quite
active in it that's like being a reptile
with the cold-blooded way of life
actually not possible but the
origin of the dinosaur
story so said is
basically the statement that they are lizards
dinosaurs are scary  lizards and that
suggests on the one hand that they belong to the
reptiles and that was so firmly
established in the
scientific community that until
actually until the 80s of the
last century that was still
the common way of thinking and here comes
the isotope, the isotope technology
to wear there are molecular
compounds that combine depending on the
temperature, for example the
mass 47 that is co2 with carbon isotope
13c and with 6 p.m. and 4 p.m. added
together and that always finds masses
independent of the city but
temperature-dependent that means we
have the technology here with the  we also
rehearse looking at very old
organisms  can and their
isotope ratio tells us something about the
formation temperature here
our brachiosaurus but also a
few other sauropods were sampled in the
various museums here
you then take the best preserved
material this
is best the enamel and measure
it in there  isotope ratio
so it's not
that we expect an organism
to value its size as cold-blooded animals
potentially getting warmer that's a
dependency that
is natural due to the size and surface volume relationship and that's how the
suspected temperature body temperatures were
determined for huge dinosaurs  and that is on the illustration
is i would have to go there briefly
on the next on the next page
i was made so you
measured this mass 47 and
reconstructed the temperature from it and you
find colder temperatures here for the two large
dinosaurs than the
expected the  on the line to s  marriage is
that would have to correlate with body size
and in absolute numbers
our brachiosaurus had a
body temperature of 38.2 degrees at
the time when the limestone formed
under camarasaurus also a large four
physicists dinosaur isotope values isotope tempe
ature of 35.7 that is  are very
close to our own body
temperature unit a bit
feverish and the other even a
bit under tempered which is actually unlikely
for these giant
organisms only if you can equalize
your own body
temperature by cooling through
sweating like we do then  you have
the possibility to keep your body temperature
constant so
physiologically that was a stupid thing to do
and you have to realize that a little
bit we have provided everything in our
with our technology a small
step or a small proof of that
which didn’t exist before
that  that was bitter were what logical
ers  seems but so far directly measurable
directly after you don't know
what happened and that's the new things
that happen here in the museum, so to speak, we look at
certain questions again with
new methods and try to find definitive proof, so to speak
,
and I think I've already got it  so
said everything said what i wanted to
say i hope i was able to show
that in the natural history collections
that we have here but also were collected worldwide we
have massive, really great
potential to
further work on the question and
with the modern techniques
we can continue to look especially with
digitization and i hope you
like it that we do it because we are of
course dependent on you as
scientists who are also paid by the state
that would be my contribution for today
thank you turn on again
yes thank you that i hope so
you got a bit of an overview
overview in the two  half a year
museum what we methodically or which
instruments he used
to solve certain questions i
would make the
following suggestion i set up
individual instruments there so
we can also have some income i
can explain a little something then there
is another one over there  showcase there are a
few instruments set up
and otherwise there are also a few in the house who
can still see each other i would
maybe
ask again if you
have questions of a general nature
then we can do them otherwise
i suggest that we maybe in front of the
devices  we would like to discuss it a bit and
let's
say thank you for your com it's a pity that the room isn't bigger
that's not bigger we would have
liked to do it but as I said thank you
for coming
and buying our book
[applause]
you said yes  it was very time-
consuming to produce these old instruments
because you could do it
te don’t do it mechanically
quickly and always the
standard was also difficult
which quantities can you
assume so how many are there
then of one should be as
estimated or more or less that
’s the same as with today’s
devices  the more specialized the devices
are, the fewer of them there are
. the highlight of microscope manufacture was
the introduction of the obligatory
trichinae inspection in
prussia  thick tube was
laid and squeezed and
people looked to see if there were any in there that brought
about an upswing in microscopy
production they were made in the
thousands these
microscopes didn't have to be of particularly high
quality the magnification didn't have to be very
large areas lower
magnification and if you do that  see  t there
were in the big slaughterhouses, e.g.
central 44 in berlin, there were souls,
mostly women, who
copied the microphones there and every single pig
or microscopy is done differently today, today
it is done biochemically,
you bring the pigs together in groups,
15 groups, and look for them  a
biochemical marker that
shows signs of Trittin and if you
haven't found it that's good and if
you've found it you have to take a closer look at these
five animals or ten animals from which
this mixed sample comes
or the clubs will get lost there they
are already  so to speak bring terrible word to the
animal body disposal facility
with polarization microscopes the
number is probably in the thousands but
not that high because every institute
pays a whole set for
students or something like that with such
things this brandao leister this
trio david instrument there are
maybe 30 40  there is
no such thing as a war from me
not even every institute could afford it that expensive, that's
the way its
machines are today, but
not every museum can afford
that, and if you then and so you have to
say the counter of this conti
meter believe something from me  you what stands there that
also had a mass instrument
every institute owned three myself
so important but the museum owns
three that is the best preserved yes
as i said they like to know each other we
can still talk about the devices there we can
discuss yes and  I'm still discussing it, so
I'm still
putting it together at the moment,
yes, ok, everything is clear, thank you again